it is the first of June 2023 so you know
what that means it's time for another
monthly update video in which I will
tell you about what we've got coming up
in June that you don't want to miss and
what you might have missed or might have
already seen in May there will be links
if you just click the see more or video
description for all the things that I'm
referencing you'll be able to find them
quite easily and both of these are
pretty busy months I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
so without any further Ado here they are
big thing number one you're going to
want to pay attention to the study with
Sadler Academy you'll also see this in
my social media because I'm going to be
bringing out some new classes that you
can enroll in people have been asking
hey I want to take classes with you so
here is is your opportunity big thing
number two and this is a double I have
two conferences that I am presenting at
in the month of June one is the American
philosophical uh practitioners
Association where I'll be talking about
anger management and and resources for
that the other is right here in town at
Marquette the Aristotle and Aristotelian
tradition conference and I will be
presenting on what logos means for
Aristotle in terms of human community
and communication and then the third
thing big thing number three is a little
bit more of something fun so you may
have seen the video or you may not have
for the banjo metaphysics T-shirt design
there's a promotion going on if you like
you know the sort of work that I do and
you want to support by buying merch I've
got a really cool cool four panel design
from a famous lecture that I gave where
I brought in my long neck banjo to talk
about Aristotle's for causes in the
metaphysics so those are the big things
and let's talk now about the month of
May
May was a long and busy month and a lot
of stuff going on we finished up classes
now Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design had finished up in late April but
I still had a student with an incomplete
and
um Marquette University where I was
teaching a class didn't finish up until
I mean officially I think like the
second week of May and then I had one
other student with an incomplete in that
as well so all of my academic teaching
is done for the Academic Year I'll be
picking up in the fall I also was able
to start getting some regular exercise
going back to the gym to do my weight
circuit taking walks around Milwaukee
you may have seen some of the images
from that and I did a lot more writing
as well I published 14 different pieces
in my various medium Publications
whether it's Gregory Sadler PhD practice
rationality or heavy metal philosopher
and we had a lot of events as well so
philosophers in the midst of History we
had our in-person session focusing on
Bonaventure talking about the Middle
Ages and the franciscans we did worlds
of speculative fiction and finished up
with Kim Stanley Robinson's Mars Trilogy
looking at Blue Mars in particular I
published the video from the event that
happened in April what is public
philosophy a pluralist proposal that was
a paper I gave at the Wisconsin
philosophical Association
we also had our understanding anger 2.0
session four and that was on Homer and
The Iliad and anger not just on the part
of Achilles but Agamemnon and all the
other people involved and then we also
had
[Music]
um
uh you know quite a few other events did
our half hour Hegel sessions
um and I had a really interesting
interview with David fideler that you
might have seen uh in the ideas that
matter series talking about ancient
stoicism the Renaissance and the
potential for using uh stoicism and the
conceptions from the Renaissance for a
Revival of culture in our present day I
mentioned the banjo metaphysics thing
there was a promotion going on that that
spring and YouTube We're partnering with
and so I participated in that and there
was a nice uh you could you could say
promotion that gave people you know 25
off on merch I'm not quite sure how long
that goes for but you can see a link to
it below and in that video I also did a
lot of video work I produced three half
hour Hegel videos so we've got some
momentum going on that it released two
of them to the public all three to
patreon supporters I did a meme Roundup
video since people were constantly
sending them to me we also published two
of the wisdom for Life shows uh the the
video recordings of the radio sessions
and I did some uh storytelling as well
so numbers 42 and 43 you can see those
linked to as well
and I also started shooting a series
very excited about this on Philip K Dix
the man in the High Castle in the
speculative fiction studies and I've
released two of them so far and we've
got many more yet to come because
there's an awful lot to explore in that
great work now when it comes to uh
podcast stuff we finished up with locked
tonsiases on the anger of God we went
through the cynic Epistles that are
attributed to kratase third skolarc of
the cynic school and then we've been
doing a lot of Seneca so I've been
releasing podcast episodes on seneca's
on anger primarily book book two and we
just started on shortness of life which
is another great cynican work so that's
all the stuff that's been going on in
the month of May
what do we have coming up in June so I'm
going to run through the events and if
you're interested in any of these you'll
see links to them for the most part
unless there's something that I still
have to create so we kick off the month
this Saturday with our usual AMA that's
asking me anything session so that's on
Saturday June 3rd at noon Central time I
should mention all of the times that I'm
giving here central time so if you're in
a different time zone make sure to check
it ama that's asked me anything usually
people ask me about philosophy but also
about you know personal matters about
music about the city that I live in and
other things as well following that at
2PM on the third we have our philosophy
chat for patreon supporters if you'd
like to become a supporter there's a
link below that you can follow it's a
great way to show some gratitude and
help me out every little bit helps as
they say the next day on the 4th at 11
A.M we'll be having storytelling or
Story Time rather with Sadler and I will
be reading doing a live reading and then
discussing a really great story uh by
Robert block called that Hellbound train
one of my favorites of all time I read
it as a kid and I was captivated by it
since it's about a guy who makes a deal
with the devil and actually comes out on
The Winning Side on the 10th at noon
Central time we'll have our worlds of
speculative fiction series and this time
we're going back to CJ chera's amazing
Alliance Union Universe looking at the
merchanter novels it's been such a joy
to re-read these and I've been you know
preparing the video for it and so that
should be a lot of fun we start out with
a video premiere and live chat and then
we move to a zoom session
on the 14th at 5 PM we'll have our uh
Hegel q a and discussion underwritten by
patreon supporters of the half hour
Hegel project so if you've got questions
you know confusions need clarifications
about Hegel or German idealism show up
and and we'll chat on the 17th we I will
be presenting at the all day long
American philosophical practitioners
Association member meeting talking about
resources for anger management primarily
an ancient philosophy but also in others
as well and now you have to become a
member in order to get access to that
but I'm going to see if they'll let me
record it or not
on the uh the 21st which is a Wednesday
I will be presenting here in town my
paper about out Aristotle and the
meaning of logos starting from politics
book one going through in a bunch of
other Aristotelian texts and I will be
going pretty much to the entire
conference lasting from Monday the 19th
to Wednesday the 24th the 21st it's
always a really great occasion for
hearing papers not just about Aristotle
but the entire Aristotelian tradition on
the 24th open to everybody but you have
to sign up for the class the free online
class we will be having our
understanding anger 2.0 class session
this time we just did Homer last time
it's going to be about Hessian another
one of the absolutely centrally
important Greek poets we're going to be
looking at anger and conflict in works
and days and in the theogony on the 25th
that's the next day a Sunday at noon
Central time we'll be having our
self-directed study advice video again
video premiere with live chat and I will
be discussing uh my advice for studying
David hume's works on your own so if
you're a big fan of humor you actually
just want to know where would I start
you want to show up for that then
finally another local event here in town
on the 30th at 6 pm at the Women's Club
of Wisconsin we'll be doing another
philosophy eats where we have a dinner
and I just bring up a topic and have
some handouts for people and we'll be
looking at the philosophy of friendship
which by the way I am getting ready to
teach a class about you notice I
mentioned classes in the study with
Sadler Academy you'll see some
announcements about that later on in the
month so stay tuned for that
um before I launch into what we're doing
as far as video work I'm I'll say this
so June is a pretty important time here
in Milwaukee we have the world's largest
Music Festival Summerfest here and
that's been going on for more than 50
years and uh my oldest kid and I are
going to be seeing Queens Reich and
Vixen and probably the hind end of
autograph because frankly we're only
interested in one song and then uh
before that though my wife and I are
taking a trip out to Ohio where we are
going to see The Cure this is a big deal
I've never seen him she's never seen
them and we had to enter a lottery to
get the tickets so that's going to be
cool I'm going to be doing a lot of
writing this month so you'll see things
coming out in medium also working on two
different book projects one on Epictetus
the commentary stuff on and Caribbean
but another I'm working on a textbook
for one of my fall classes ethics for
artists and designers so that's going to
be kind of cool all right video work
what am I going to be shooting obviously
more half hour Hegel videos I've got a
couple people lined up for the ideas
that matter conversation videos the
interview things including my good
friend Scott tiruli and most likely my
wife and partner Andy Shaka and maybe
some other people as well
I'll be doing some personal videos and
uh doing some of the long overdue book
reviews that I need to get to that I
didn't get to this month and uh you'll
see a lot more videos on Philip K Dick's
man in the High Castle I should be able
to get through the entire Series this
month I think and I'll be doing a lot
more Shorts YouTube short videos that
people seem to like and if I have the
time I'll do some core concept videos on
aquinas's five ways and that's already a
lot of stuff in addition to all the
event videos podcast stuff
um we've got you know we started with
seneca's on the shortness of life and
then we'll come back to book three of
his on anger and then once we finished
up with the Seneca stuff we can go to
another great stoic Marcus Aurelius and
I shot a whole bunch of videos on his
meditations we'll be taking those and
turning them into podcast episodes as
well so there you have it a lot of stuff
going on in June that hopefully you want
to get in on a lot of stuff that
happened in May that you might find
interesting so I hope you can join me
for some of these online events if
you're here in person in the Milwaukee
area maybe come to some of the local
things if you want to as well and I hope
you have a great month ahead summer is
beginning for all of us which is a a
very fun time here in the Milwaukee area
so you'll see lots of pictures of of my
walks and things like that so that's
that's all for me folks as I mentioned
if you want to know more about any of
these things links are below you just
got to click show more video description
and they'll pop up and I will see you
somewhere in The Ether